they want to say that this is 300 v1 is
30 meters per second this angle here is
sine inverse of 4 1 5 which seems
awkward at first but they're actually
doing us a favor
as you'll see shortly this angle here is
sine inverse of 3/5 and that's all this
is
okay so what they want us to do is find
what v2 is so how do I do that assuming
these two collide
yeah okay good so given all the
information that they provide and this
which we proved in the first part okay
I'm going to take this equation get rid
of the rest because I'm not interested
in it and the to that second velocity
right that's the only constant that I
don't know the value of I know it v1 v1
and feel okay so therefore I'm saying
since the particles will collide so I
don't want to bring this equation out of
nowhere I want to say why am i green you
know I'm gonna take this original
actually gonna take the values that they
supply us okay so that looks like 30
sine of sine inverse equals V T that's
my unknown sign oh okay
okay
no sir no just just based on what
they've said just based on what they
said and remember I'm thinking about it
my x-coordinate for the second particle
right I've slapped a minus on it anyway
which is actually gonna do the same
thing as sine 180 - does that make sense
so it's gonna send me in the right
direction even if I take it as an acute
angle okay yeah on acute angles that's
actually really important to notice
because at this point here I'm trying to
solve for v2 right now your next time
probably you think Oh sine is sine
inverse that'll just be 4/5 right so
you're right 30 times 4 over 5 which is
correct okay but how much do you
remember
on the inverse tree I can't simply say
that sine of sine inverse something is
something why not why can't I just say
that it is missing
maybe signing those right this only
works with certain values right sign
even this doesn't go for redline we
restrict it in a certain place right now
when you come to here why can I just
take this value and not come up with
some other one it's because I have some
restrictions on theta1 and theta2 namely
that they're both acute okay because if
they were obtuse they would fire off in
another direction different from what
the question is defined and if they were
reflex they would be blowing themselves
up because they fire at the ground okay
so I can simplify this part and also the
right-hand side but the reason I can say
that is because I know not inclusive I
know that these angles are acute okay
and that's the important thing not to
miss okay that's why I can simply cancel
this out right if it wasn't if these
many angles were safe up to you solve
reflux in some other kind of situation
and this is not going to be quite so
neat we'll deal with that later
now here it's just a simple result v2
equals multiply that through because the
result is known I'm not just gonna write
down v2 equals 40 I'm gonna put this
over here so you can see where my
working is so that's why I can cancel
cancel now I can say 40
okay always provide more lines of
working when they provide users zone all
right show that and that the particles
collide after four seconds okay so I
know what this second speed is now you
remember that what's confusing one of
the things that's confusing about this
topic is it there are so many different
equations flying around which one should
I go to in order to show that the planet
was collide at a certain time where'd
you go have a look at your equations
that you got written down
yes okay now why go back to my ex
equation okay I could go back to my Y
equation right pretty nice my ex
equations are better choice why
okay number one it's simpler number two
right it's still got after simplifying
it out it's still got a T in it right
when we took our Y equation and we just
slapped it together the T disappeared
okay well that's kind of not a very good
place to go for number one cuz no Tina
number two it's where I came from
I'm just gonna get you know 50 equals 50
first prize
see remarks okay so don't do that go
back to your X equation right particles
collide when okay so he's the equation
that I would write
okay so you can see now where my on
where my a B has come in here it is
right and now the rest of it is just
subbing stuff out there you have to be
careful because of this cosine here but
let's have a think about how this is
gonna work out b1 is 30 T cos off sine
inverse be careful equals 200 - okay
know again I'm gonna evaluate this in a
second and again just like before when I
go over to my inverse trig functions I
have to note that these angles are acute
but how do I get rid of these when I've
got cos and sine in this together what
do I do
yeah good George Rangel now for over
five maybe at this point you like oh I
know what kind of triangle this is it's
just a 3 4 5 triangle right that's
terrible scale I'm sorry it's a sine
inverse 4 or 5 which angle is that in
this triangle it's it's this one over
here in the corner right so cos is
adjacent and hypotenuse here okay so
this part here 30 T times instead of 405
will be 3 over 5 that's all
see how it's gone to the other ratio
this will be 200 minus 40 T times and
this will work exactly the same way but
every of us okay all right now where are
ya you can I think you can simplify from
here you're gonna land on okay you
satisfied with what